لقد قام الطيارون بعمل لا يصدق حقًا ،
أعني أننا جئنا فيها كان موقفًا مخيفًا
ولكنه كان سلسًا للغاية كما لو
كان تجربة رائعة
لم تكن تجربة متشنجة ، لقد عدنا للتو
إلى الهواء وجئنا  مرة أخرى
وهبطت ، كان آدم جونسون على متن
طائرة JetBlue رقم 206 القادمة من ناشفيل ،
وأمر بإجهاض هبوط الطائرة ، وقال إنه كان
يعلم أن شيئًا ما معطل ولكن لم يكن لديه أي دليل على
المكالمة القريبة التي كان يواجهها في
اليوم التالي في الأخبار ،
هذه واحدة من أكثرها
المراحل الضعيفة من الرحلة هي أيضًا حيث تكون
حركة المرور هي الأكثر كثافة وفقًا لإدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) ليلة
الاثنين كان من الواضح أن رحلة JetBlue من
ناشفيل كانت واضحة للهبوط قبل
السابعة بقليل عندما خططت Learjet لاستخدام
Crossing Runway دون الحصول على
إذن أمرت رحلة JetBlue
بالإجهاض  الهبوط وأداء الدوران
حول الجميع متجهًا إلى أه لذا
كنت جالسًا على ارتفاع ثلاثة
آلاف وثلاثة آلاف تتبعًا من
Flight Radar 24 يظهر أن
رحلة JetBlue قادمة من أسفل
الشاشة Learjet فقط إلى اليسار
تسحب للخارج أمام  في نهاية المطاف ،
انسحبت رحلة JetBlue وعادت
حول إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية ، وتقول إن طيار
طائرة JetBlue قد اتخذ إجراء مراوغًا
وبدأ في الصعود عندما
عبرت Learjet التقاطع ، وتقول إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية إن
Learjet كررت تعليماتها
بالبقاء في مكانها ولكن في النهاية أقلعت على أي حال
كان مجرد أحدث مثال على
مكالمة قريبة في مطار نيويورك كان لدى جون كينيدي في نيويورك
حالة مماثلة الأسبوع الماضي في بوربانك
كاليفورنيا ،
مما جعل الكثيرين يتساءلون عما يحدث
وهذا بالضبط ما نريده جميعًا أن نعرف
روبرت سوموالت الرئيس السابق
للمواطن.  يقول مجلس سلامة النقل إن
حوادث المكالمات القريبة آخذة في
الارتفاع من حوالي الثامنة في العام إلى ما
يقرب من 20 في المتوسط ​​مع تحقيق إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) الآن
وسيريدون حقًا
معرفة ما إذا كان
انهيار اتصالاتهم كان هناك
إلهاء متورط من جانبه
تقول JetBlue إن السلامة في JetBlue هي
أولويتنا الأولى وأن أطقمنا مدربة
على الرد على مثل هذه المواقف